joining me right now on the phone uh his
tweet this morning certainly
got our attention we had emanuel sanders
on the show yesterday and i asked
emmanuel
uh if there was a preseason game right
now tonight
would uh the saints and would other
members of the nfl
not play it he said that they would that
he didn't see
you know why taking away a game in which
his colleagues would need it to make a
team
would be something that that the rest of
the nfl players would be willing to do
but again let's put jim trotter's tweet
up here nfl owners should be careful
a few prominent black players are
telling me they want to sit out a game
to make their feelings felt and force
change action they're tired frustrated
and emotional
only a few at this point but sparks
become flames and flames become infernos
very vivid imagery
from my colleague from the nfl media
group jim trotter back here on the show
how are you jim
i'm good how you doing i appreciate your
patience hanging on hold uh
here on the on this friday i love
hearing about the richardson show.com
i appreciate you know what there's my my
phrase is if not me who and if not now
when so
you know it applies to so many things in
life no doubt so uh
walk me through your tweet and um and
and
all the way from your your information
gathering to you hitting send on it
yeah you know rich i had been hearing
some of this yesterday
and particularly after the lions decided
to cancel practice and
and um even within team buildings and
team meetings there have been players
who have brought this up and raised the
idea of players sitting out games but
i guess what really got me this morning
you know in the six o'clock hour i got a
call from a player very prominent player
and
he was really emotional about it and
said he had been crying for three days
and
and said enough's enough and and um
he believed that a real statement and
cause for action could be made by black
players
sitting out a game and
it was something he was going to talk to
two other players about
so again you know people want to go from
a to z
um right away when a tweet is put out
and that's why i tried to make it clear
that this is not some large group
of players that i've heard from it is a
few but the fact that a few prominent
players are talking about it
um could spark you know sort of a
movement among these guys and
and it i'm not gonna lie to you rich the
call this morning was unsettling
you know to hear a man that emotional
and that in that much pain about what's
going on
um it truly is bigger than football
for for some of these guys and and
that's why i think the owners would be
smart
to be proactive on this instead of
reactive and what we know about the nfl
traditionally is that it is a reactive
league and not a proactive league and
and if it doesn't prepare for this um
it's not it potentially it could not be
pretty
well and again i'm going to have this
conversation with um
chris haynes of yahoo whose report today
about what the players discussed
wednesday night um after the
cancellation of games
um you know the the the conversation
that apparently the players even had
first blush uh in the nba on wednesday
night
uh is similar to i guess the question
i'm going to have here is what
what would be considered concrete enough
action
to um prevent a player from sitting out
or this player that you spoke to today
the answer is different from it for
for everyone obviously i mean players
aren't a monolith you know but i would
say at the end of the day the one thing
that all
of the black players that i talk to want
is for um
unarmed black people to stop being
killed by the police
by the way plus plus one on that jim
so how do we get there becomes the
question and i think
i think with with players at this point
who are starting to discover their voice
and starting to discover their power and
and and and how much power there is in
unity
i think what they would like to see at
least what i'm hearing from owners is
they want to see the owners step out
front
and be a partner in this and not just
put out statements and and make
donations
but to actually be out front and use
their political capital and political
influence
that they have to try and and make
change and
you know and i've thrown this out there
and this has not come from a player it's
just me speaking
is that we know the league is involved
with a voter registration drive which is
tremendous
and and there is talk of opening up
state uh stadiums
for polling places but how about if if
the owners got out front
on camera with their players and said
for instance
um we want and we demand that
the voter rights reform bill by the late
john lewis
be put on the senate floor which mitch
mcconnell has not brought to the floor
those sorts of things are action those
sorts of things can lead to change
and i think that's what players are
looking for now from ownership
is to step out front with them to be
visible
and to try and make change and what i
was told yesterday by a union source is
that back in 2018
when the nfl and the players association
were discussing um
changes to the anthem policy that one of
the things players
left there with was a sense and a
feeling from some owners that these
owners were going to use their political
influence and that's the term that was
used to me political influence
to make real change and so now it is
about
that i i think players want to hold
owners accountable on this
and so i think that that's a step in
terms of moving it in the right
direction because look rich the reality
is that the players have demonstrated to
raise awareness
they have sparked conversations and yet
unarmed black people are still being
killed by the police
that's the reality jim trotter my
colleague from the nfl media group here
on the rich eisen show well what what uh
have you spoken to any players about
i guess what would the ravens statement
that
was remarkable in its detail that you
i've never seen something like that from
a sports
franchise let alone an nfl franchise is
that something that would be considered
substantial but if you read the
statement and and i applaud the
statement as i did yesterday and when i
but if you read the statement that says
we can demand these things
well let's take out the word can and
just say we demand these things
i mean it's one word we're omitting
there but it makes a world of difference
in terms of possible change so
um and i'm not trying to in any way put
down what the ravens did i think it was
tremendous to have
have an ownership group step out front
and
again and recognize the core issue of
what's going on here just as the 49ers
did when they put out their statement
back in the day about systemic racism
being at the core of everything that is
happening here
so but let's take out what we can do and
let's say let's do it
you know stop talking and be about the
action
what did you think jim um and what other
players that you're speaking to think of
the commissioner's appearance on
emmanuel achos program i i
truly rich i haven't talked to them
about that and i think you know my
feelings on it because i
i spoke on it on air um in my opinion
that that
was not uncomfortable at all the only
ones that that was uncomfortable for
were for the listeners
who were waiting to hear real questions
be asked of the commissioner on that
look when the commissioner says we we
could have listened earlier
well you heard the players for two years
you saw them demonstrate you heard
what they wanted you even negotiated
with the players coalition to come up
with
a program to try and address some of
these issues so to say
that you didn't listen that's not true
you heard them you chose not to listen
you chose not to act on it because
after two years you went into an owners
meeting and changed the anthem policy to
prevent players from demonstrating on
the field
during the star spangled banner so again
if i'm
if i'm doing that interview with the
commissioner among the things i said
that i would like to have heard
ask is number one we know that the
commissioner's father stood up on
principle stood against
president um nixon during the vietnam
war
at the cost of his job showed tremendous
courage
well i wonder did the commissioner think
about that when he was thinking about
how to handle the colin kaepernick
situation when colin took a knee
you know back in 2018 when the owners
changed the anthem policy
was there ever any consideration given
to the fact that when you change that
policy to prevent these players from
demonstrating on the field
during the anthem that the appearance is
that you value
your pocketbooks more than you value a
black life you know back in
in 06 when roger was named commissioner
he went out and met with dr harry
edwards
and dr harry edwards told him at that
time the demographics of the league are
changing
and more black players are coming in and
they're going to become the face of the
league
and they are not going to leave their
communities at the locker room door
so with a decade to prepare for that
moment how is it that the nfl was so
unprepared when colin took a knee
and lastly after he took a knee dr
edwards also told roger do not make him
a martyr
and yet the owners turned around and
made colin a martyr a martyr
so for me those are things that i would
want to hear answered um
you know if i were doing the interview
with the commissioner at that point just
some of the things
so that's that's what you thought of the
interview huh
so what's the next made me uncomfortable
well so what's the next step
jim what do you what do you think yeah
step is action rich
it's it's not about talk anymore you
know it's not even about demonstrating
anymore it's about
action now and if the nfl is a family
as we've seen in the slogans and the ads
and this that and the other
on television and whatnot then owners
step with your players if you believe
that what they are fighting for is right
then stand out front with them and and
make change
use that political capital look we know
it's been reported that nine of the top
16 sports donors
to presidents president trump's
inauguration or re-election campaign
were nfl owners and you only pay that
kind of money for
access and influence well now use that
access
use that influence to try and make real
change
to make legislative change systemic
change that
to me is progress in this fight because
look rich this isn't going to be
going to going to be solved in a day
it's not going to be solved in a year
you know but what you do now lays the
foundation for what comes going forward
and
and for instance when i talked to that
player this morning he said we
understand you know that we're trying to
do something for the generation that's
going to come behind us so
um to discount or to minimize
what these players are feeling and what
they are thinking
in my opinion would be a grave mistake
by the owners in the nfl at this point
last one for you jim where is kaepernick
now what is what what is happening
with him i don't know football also um
you know being public face front social
justice wise
he does a lot of stuff as we know uh
with his
um organization behind the scenes or
right
let's just put it this way not not
publicly to
uh put out a statement right like he
does he does things
but the question is like what now i'm
like where where
is he right now you don't know huh
nobody knows i don't know
i hear nothing i hear nothing i really
hear nothing we've been told that but
um i can't speak on where he is or or
what's happening right now
does that is that odd to you or is that
or is this
right you know wha what do you think jim
seriously
about look colin has made a decision on
how he wants to go about handling this
and
and even back in as recently i shouldn't
say as recently
but as far back as 2017-2018 i was told
that
one of the reasons he does not speak a
lot publicly it's because he does not
want the media to be able to twist his
words
and change the narrative as they did
when he took a knee during the anthem
so i understand that but then you have
another group that says look if you want
to be the face of this then you have to
be out front on it he has chosen to
handle it this way that's his
prerogative
jim i really appreciate it um and uh i
always appreciate when you come on the
show and we'll chat again soon
football's literally right around the
corner and um
it's exciting and it's also uh anxious
there's a lot going on but i i it sure
looks like this is gonna go off
in a couple weeks rich you gotta hand me
on next time to talk about something
lighter
jim how about next week but you never
know do it let's do it i'll do it i'll
have you on it because i mean i'd love
to talk with you about
um you know the game but obviously the
real world is
is uh bigger than the game question so
thanks for the time appreciate it
i'm just giving you a hard time no i
know jim but i i you know your your
tweet certainly caught my eye
you know so i just wanted to have you on
a to you know uh
get a little bit more uh information
behind it and i appreciate you
delivering it
rich eisenshow.com that's true thank you
brother that's right thank you very much
jim that's jim trotter everybody right
here on the rich eisen show
there we go it's jim trotter underscore
nfl right so just get her out there
as well he's mentioning our we we should
return in kind yes